so let's think about all of the
different ways that we can represent
seven
ninths
seven
ninths so let's just visualize seven
ninths
so here i have nine equal sections and
seven ninths you could represent as
seven of those equal sections so let me
get our set get myself a
a bigger thing to draw with so that i
can fill this in fast
which i don't like how that looks i'm
gonna use
the paintbrush
so here we go so that's one
two
three
four
you know where this is going five
six and seven so that's one way of
representing seven ninths we already
know that that's not too interesting but
let's see if we can represent seven
ninths as a sum of other fractions
so let's imagine
maybe we can represent it as
let's do it as 2 9.
give my use a different brush here so
let's represent it as
2 9
2
over 9
plus
plus i don't know
let's see maybe 3
over 9 but that doesn't quite get us to
7 9 yet 2 over 9 plus 3 over 9 is going
to get us to 5 over 9 so we're going to
need two more so it's going to be plus
another 2 over 9
plus another 2
over 9
plus another 2 over 9. so what would
this look like
so let's
let's just
draw another grid here
so this is going to look like i'll try
to do it right below it so that we can
see
how they match up so we have two ninths
we have two ninths this two ninths right
over here well we have each of these is
a ninth we have nine equal sections so
two ninths is going to be
so we're gonna get one
and two
and then we're gonna add three more
ninths
so one
one two
three
so we had three ninths right over there
and then two more nines
and then two more nines one
one
and two
so notice when i added two ninths to
three-ninths to
two-ninths
this equals seven-ninths and we know
that when we add a bunch of fractions
like this that have the same denominator
we can just add the numerator and this
is why this is 2 9 plus 3 9 times 2 9 is
going to give me 7 9. let's do this one
more time this is actually a lot of fun
so let me draw my grid again
let me draw my grid
and then let's let's see what we can do
so let me get my pen tool out
pen tool out and make sure my
my ink isn't too
thick oh this is fine and let's add a
couple of knights here so let's add
let's add first 1 9
and i'm going to write all the nines in
blue and let's add two knights
and then we could add
i don't know maybe we could add
let me give some space here so we can
add more and maybe we could add
three nights
three nights
and then we could add let's see
that won't get us he sees one ninth well
actually let me just write this i'm
going to try to add
four fractions here so let's add first
one-ninth see where that gets us so
one-ninth is going to get us right over
here
so that's one-ninth
so let's say we add two-ninths to that
so two-ninths
ninths get my little paint brush going
on so that's one
and two more
two knights
so that still doesn't get us there this
gives us a total of three nines one plus
two is three three ninths so let's say i
don't know let's add
let's add
let's add four ninths
four ninths and i'll do that in this
blue color
so four nights
that's well that's different enough
four nights so let's see where this gets
us
actually well why not so four ninths
and so that's going to get us one
two
three
4 so that looks like it got us all the
way because 1 plus 2 plus 4 is going to
give us 7 7 9. so what could we put here
well we could say 0 9 why not
so we could put in
we could call this one right over here
zero ninths and how would we visualize
that well that's we're saying none of
these no no ninths right over here so
this is one ninth plus two nines plus
four ninths is equal to
seven nine so these are all different
ways to decompose the exact same
fraction